over 100 days of bombs and destruction
some Palestinians in Gaza have returned
to the ruins of where they once lived
it's become a way to gather and console
each other one of those women is um Al
AB she lost her home and many members of
her family in an Israeli strike on Rafa
she tells us how she and her remaining
family are trying to
cope I no longer have a home All That
Remains are these ruins
these have become my home I gather my
daughters and we start reminiscing we
remember that Abid was killed here Hamid
died there kareim lost his life there
and my grandchildren were killed in that
corner we shed tears sometimes we cry
our eyes out sometimes we're overwhelmed
with
Serenity this is our life this is our
home we spend all day
here we were gathering at home and all
of a sudden the roof fell on our heads I
told my son we should leave he refused
and said where can we
go within seconds we were hit again with
another missile my son's daughters were
around me some were injured others
passed out when she was conscious again
she started crying in Weeping for losing
our home I told her let's take my
grandchildren to your sister's home and
we can return here again the father
refused and said we should not leave our
home we live here and we die
here we are like all other
gazin after a while Amed came back
crying oh grandmother my father my
brothers and sisters and my uncles were
killed they were all killed I asked him
what happened and he said oh grandmother
our home was bombed and they were all
killed
inside